[Musique]
le crypto challenge c'est donc un jeu
dédié autour des codes secrets on a des
textes qui sont cryptés d'une certaine
manière ou lélex les lettres sont
interchanger et le but est de retrouver
le texte originel à partir d'un 10
et cette année il y a un tout un jeu
d'énigmes autour d'une figure
scientifique s'appelle ada lovelace et
le crypto challenge ne consiste plus
uniquement à décrypter des textes qui
n'ont rien à voir les uns les autres
mais à avancer sous une forme de jeu de
piste à del vallès une figure qui est un
méconnu des des sciences c'est une
comtesse qui était très doué en
mathématiques
c'était la première moitié du 19e siècle
et elle a travaillé sur une machine
sur les plans d'une machine qui
s'appelle la machine analytique qui est
considéré un peu comme l'ancêtre de
l'ordinateur
je me suis dis bah je vais pas en faire
profiter que mes élèves puisque c'est
quelque chose qui se passe sur internet
et je vais l'ouvrir à tout public
enfants et adultes
[Musique]